[Music]
it's not worth it news it's not worth it
trust me
submitted by Jesus chan I was gonna see
when I tasted something I don't know any
of them does he ever original music he's
like a album or - is everybody taller
than me
did you do a song called expensive I'm
in love with my best friend
no that's Jason Chan really I think is
Aylin in love with my best friend that's
a nice song yeah I'm in love with my
best can you give me this can a woman
fatally ran over a nail salon worker to
avoid paying the $35 manicures I've
heard about this you saw it yeah
somebody $35 I didn't see a video I only
seemed like the hairline the pictures
and the captions she looked like she's
there's a lot of drugs in Vegas and she
her life is just sorrows yes in Vegas
her name is Krystal she's 21 years old
crystal jail crystal meth crystal meth
no man it's crystal job it would quit no
jail that's also part of Angela
Johnson's old bit that were hella viral
before viral as a thing
it was the only successful stand a bit
and she's still doing shows based off of
that biz she's still making wipe off
thank you put me on Angela Johnson my
college counselor I was walking by that
my counselor building oh my god this
Asian will appreciate this yeah there's
two counselors dying of laughter
have you seen this what was like why did
otherwise Mexican not my counselor but
in the counseling department oh it's so
funny go oh you never saw this and then
they're a planetoid I was laughing dude
oh this is really good I love that white
person laughter just I it was really fun
I can literally see a choke up out of
your mouth
yeah Mexican see the hahaha the GE
crystal she was driving a stolen rental
black Chevy Camaro aniseh rental and is
refurbished she's trying to pay for her
nails with a golden card card oh my god
this is a thief through and through I
know what a [ __ ] she's like oceans
eight character well they call their
fraudulent card so that's the same thing
yeah but yeah it was B yeah okay she
says that she's gonna go get cash from
her car but then she ends up turning on
her car and that's when knock when she
goes just try to stop her with her
longtime boyfriend who he calls himself
husband wife she died she died
oh my dragged her body oh yeah she ran
her over drag went in front of the car
right yeah so I'm gonna show you the
video why she's too brave what's your
soap tank focus you don't think you
don't think anyone's gonna run you over
like no one in the right mind does that
I do I never want to stand in front of a
car yeah unless I have a gun cuz I know
people won't run people over then I'll
shoot them while they're trying to drive
me over I think you right drive over me
what do you mean a car one but why would
you do that
arguing what are you [ __ ] what we did
like Presley got to live and I got I
think people just don't know the extent
to how crazy people can be like I die if
I'm especially if you're arguing with
someone you don't want to stand in front
of a car
yeah but then in the heat of the moment
you don't think of things I think maybe
cuz we don't get that level of angry so
we don't understand yeah I wouldn't
expect it so you guys didn't grow up
with any real gangsters no because if
you did y'all know [ __ ] like that
happens like all the time people run
people over maybe because they weren't
maybe because it was in the hood no
instead of in the front of the car
know what the fun thing to do was when I
was younger and I learned this from the
older homies is for you to put a bat in
your car but have baseball mitts and
baseballs have pawned all the homies
call me nauseous OC right it's it's
transferable everywhere wait wait to do
one is for the cops right when you get
pulled over and the back in like the
early 90s there was no one knew their
rights so everyone's getting out of the
car sitting on the car that kind of
stuff so if you had a baseball bat and
baseball mitt or whatever you can pass
that on my son always has a non weapon
now I know but then you use it because
there's a lot of times you need to use a
baseball bat and you never know the more
you know yeah I can't believe that's not
common sense to not stand in front of a
car when you're arguing with someone no
you would think right but then when
you're arguing are you understand seeing
red and not thinking clearly exactly
that's why I don't stand in front of a
car because I understand seeing red I'm
saying when you're in the moment to
you're just so he's also saying that
you're not thinking clearly to to
calculate that exactly oh yeah cuz when
I'm angry I'm still not standing in
front of a car oh yeah you're right yeah
yeah you know yeah so you tell me if
you're seeing red and someone pulls out
a knife you would grab the knife and go
I'm seeing red oh that's the same thing
as the cause it's not cuz it's not often
that you're gonna get ran over with a
car but it's pretty often that if
someone pulls a knife out on you you're
gonna get static I mean guess the car is
a weapon too but it's a knob more
obvious what's it saying that that's how
they view it though standing in front of
a car is you're provoking someone with a
loaded weapon that's how I see exactly
yeah I played over - yeah didn't I
cream she's trying to stop I would have
been like stop [ __ ] yeah but they would
have stopped cuz you're white if
someone's trying to get away let's say
this person actually robbed someone with
a weapon right and she's running out the
bank with bags full of cash someone
stands at further cargos stop in the
name of the law
guess what most of those people are
gonna get rapped I wouldn't do it in
that circle right but just a little girl
running away from her man and curious
and she thinks that if she stops in
front of it if she stands in front of
the car she's gonna stop cuz she's
probably a weak [ __ ] like she's just
this just a small but you're playing
with fire assuming she's a weak [ __ ]
she thought she might be on drugs I get
it she might be crate like I'll never
said in front of a car now please don't
because that's just crazy but see the my
thing is this is that you can do that I
could see it happening with somebody
that you know right for example yeah for
me it was my boyfriend exactly see I see
that I can see that happening that's
different which I still wouldn't do but
I can understand the psychology behind
it and there's only because my parents
owned a business so whenever somebody
tried to run and steal [ __ ] my mom did
that what she grabbed the girl and the
girl's sock my mom you know yeah so like
from then on like we never told her to
like when they take stuff just let them
pay but the worst expensive a gun yeah
you don't you don't know what's avoid
the competition oh you know like whether
like you said are you from the hood or
whatever or not cuz like I never was in
a lot of violent situations so I my
white you scare me protected mind would
think that standing in front of the car
that it would stop them because if
you're in a fight with another white
person yeah they're gonna stop you know
what blows my mind is that when that TSA
incident happened at the airport you
just I [ __ ] like yeah so then you do
sense danger but it's just in such a
reason that I told you guys this
millions of times but we were both at
the airport and then right at the metal
detector area right this guy comes
running back he was fighting the eight
and he was fighting the agent
and he keeps blew right past me and I
was just watching the whole thing go
down and when I looked up she was
already way gone damn she love you
please well cuz my danger census didn't
go off I just saw like oh this guy's a
[ __ ] he probably has drugs and you're
running away from the cops Oh someone's
fighting the TSA all I'm thinking is
[ __ ] 911 right like that's just all
I'm thinking I'm like I'm gonna get away
from this bomb have you got towards like
the inside do you go out he was trying
to leave he's trying to leave that's why
I was like he took something in there
and he's trying to get out so I was like
I'm getting the [ __ ] out - and he'll
fend for himself because he's smart
that's nice like once a long time ago oh
I mean you do have dangerous senses it's
just different dangerous senses yours is
the white people danger 9/11 terror
alert and mine is the ghetto sensor
ghetto spidey sense like you no one's
real danger yeah we're not when I'm like
poking people can get and you also
probably never dated a gangster because
I've seen guys run their girlfriends
over and girlfriend's mother guy yeah
girlfriends [ __ ] try to light their
boyfriend's car on fire inside of an
argument
[ __ ] crowbar to the windshield I've
seen [ __ ] like that okay yeah so that's
why I like I was yes there's a lot Gina
says she took a golf club to her
ex-boyfriends car remember yes allegedly
Gina's telling the truth I see a little
crazy behind her at school I remember
this girl named Nancy she was standing
in the middle of the quad during lunch
and her little boyfriend little five
foot two nothing gangster came up and
just soft her the nose yep you just went
Wow puts their nose blood everywhere
goods have no problems hitting problems
that's why because I know how animal
people can be yeah I'm just like all
right I take it back media try to walk
all this [ __ ] but now that you guys are
talking about number these things right
give you the good life I gave you the
good life kissing I know what that two
dudes on the street those are the kind
of fights that we enjoy their I'd like
five already if I was like 17 and I saw
that [ __ ] you fight I would go in with
my friend and fight those guys just get
down what video alright sad times sad
times I think I've been avoiding the sad
time yeah here we go
our investigation determined that a
woman went into Chris toenails got a
manicure and then attempted to pay with
a fraudulent credit card when the credit
card payment didn't go through the
customer said that she would get cash
from her car it's a nice campus salon
owners noticed that the customer was
starting to drive away and ran out to
stop her
the owner jumped in front of the
suspects VMO or her husband was at the
back of the car at which time the
suspect no email in front of the car
well she's dead the vehicle and later
died oh you are holding on you just saw
when the car went over her body
crushed her organs did oh my god that's
$35 dude yeah she was a mother of three
oh yeah you gotta stay to the side of
the car big on the hood and the we like
worked hard for her family of course
like every Asian immigrant just run out
and take a picture of this license I
love what's really sad though is that
they're they are so concerned about that
money too because I feel like they're in
sometimes those nail salons like their
workers are treated like [ __ ] like if
they don't have that money like they're
like probably working indentured servant
style that's why she was willing to run
out there and risk her life for the
[ __ ] $35 didn't they mention she was
the owner
oh she was good then okay well she was
going to the I feel like that dude was
that go to the
front you know we're going to pincer
then that's some sad ass [ __ ] you know
it's so sad so they've started go for me
to help the family in the funeral
Costner the GoFundMe is not going to
help relieve the fact that they don't
have a mother anymore dude isn't a
second year at UC Berkeley Oh got some
smartass kids - I think Nevada is a
death penalty state actually on the run
yeah cuz they need to find her and her
mom went on the Meuse and said like you
can't run baby you cannot run you have
to come forward baby I am so sorry that
you lost your mom and I'm talking to the
girls and I can't I couldn't imagine how
you feel and I hope that you find it in
your heart to forgive my daughter and my
family you will not I will never I will
never for in fact I want you dead -
because you raised a piece of [ __ ] yeah
she'd say I am sorry for raising and
failing yeah life don't talk about
forgiveness at this point yeah a little
too early for who are you asking for
forgiveness [ __ ] this is knocking her
boyfriend how can you give forgiveness
before you apologize [ __ ] come out and
say you [ __ ] up as a mother and you
[ __ ] up with life that's why your
[ __ ] daughter's a crack addict this
is crystal she looks like crystal meth
she has a record like a prior mugshot
fire
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag I wonder where
she's hiding crack rock she's hiding
under a crack rock hiding at the Golden
Nugget
[Music]
[Music]